stop I don't know about you but I am
outraged out tweets here see words there
even the Flying Nun got involved I'm not
kidding The Flying Nun is throwing the
c-word around on Twitter like a nasty
little frisbee what is happening to
America what is happening to people so
what do we learn from this week of
outrage well used to be that would cost
you your job
was that thing you did behind a tree at
the company picnic if you're laughing
you know nope
now it's Twitter the one-stop Career
liquidator all it takes is one idiotic
statement and you disappear faster than
a Twinkie and Michael Moore's lap where
would I be without my cohorts lap I'd be
out of jokes okay as the online world
encourages mob action over forgiveness
companies now need to protect themselves
so Twitter has become a global human
resources as the population combines as
a moral force to decide who stays and
who goes
and let's not forget on Twitter the
world's bathroom wall all inscriptions
are permanent you are branded you're
branded for life of course you can't
just blame Twitter it didn't write that
tweet Roseanne and every company has the
right to fire you over words freedom of
speech without consequences only exists
against the government but this week the
offenses weren't only on Twitter or by
Roseanne two women said bad things and
one apologized and lost their job one
apologized and kept their job that's
life but let's be clear I accept all
apologies if you're sorry I accept it I
say this knowing that this favor may
never be returned to me there are
organizations devoted to catching me
screw up it's true
it's true but I will forgive all even if
even if they would end me with glee so
let's do this simple exercise if I had
said what Samantha bee said about the
daughter of a president how long would I
last I'd be frog marched into a vat of
truck drivers back sweat I would have
requested that actually but as righties
experienced boycotts lefties get awards
so it's not just about the offense
really it's about the tribe and one
tribe is less forgiving than the other
see I'm willing to forgive blunders but
I don't think there's any reciprocity
over there at the left and why is that
well Krauthammer said it first you think
they're stupid they think you're evil
meaning a conservative believes a
liberal is mistaken but a liberal
believes a conservative is immoral it's
a huge difference and behavior toward a
righty is then excused because after all
you're bad if someone is evil you can do
anything to them you can mimic their
beheading you can call a mom a c-word
for posting a picture of her child you
can wish death on Americans just for fun
so we all knew B would survive because
that's the real story we knew she was
safe because in the contemporary
landscape the liberal Joker's heart is
always in the right place after all
Ivanka she had it coming she's a mom and
her dad's evil but such logic will lead
to a dark and violent place if one group
sees you as evil what stops others from
moving beyond speech remember the
anti-shah The Weather Underground the
Unabomber I've been all major violence
the kind of the mass killing variety
didn't start with mmm I disagree with
you no it was you're evil and we must
stop you now Trump's triggered some
seriously angry people Kathy Griffin the
Decapitator in chief she still sees
herself as the victim there's Tom Arnold
oh man
sad case Chelsea Handler what happened
Kimmel Oberman is back Sarah Silverman
who wanted a military coup Robert De
Niro who threatened to punch the
president coursers Alec Baldwin
then there's sad Jim Carrey and now even
the flying frickin none this breaks my
heart I love Sally Field but these
people are so broken by Trump that they
no longer see you as human but as a
problem I guess after the Obama era all
this losing is unknown territory so we
were watching a national tantrum for
spoiled brats so what do you do if
political adversaries want you ruined
but you just want them healthy enough so
you could debate them if they're
constantly demanding scalps shouldn't we
do the same a sort of mutually assured
career destruction is that the only way
to get everyone to stop the outrage
crusade to see that it goes both ways
I don't know that is not me and it
shouldn't be you either
[Applause]
let's welcome tonight yes
he's got more good humor than the ice
cream man TV writer and producer Rob
long short of credit there don't talk to
him without a nurse because they'll put
you in stitches writer in community
David Angelo she drinks her own tears to
stay hydrated natural review reporter
cat Tim and he stole his pinkie ring
from Saturn former WWE Superstar my
massive sidekick Tyrus
Rob you were a big-time Hollywood
producer cheers that Jim stole that Dell
what's that other show a recent
cancellation yes I've been there yes you
canceled you were canceled but you did
nothing racist no no we just didn't
didn't hold our audience that's why you
did okay
great contemporary reference with the
flying nuns fantastic if you are under
80 years old of the show on 50 years ago
half a century ago did you see your
tweet I did I did Sally Fields tweet
elegant use the c-word to defeat to
actually pile on Ivanka which is like
everybody was trying to out gross each
other right well that's what they do
they like trying to act like it's not a
big deal or to pile on or something I
mean it's slightly different I mean that
the the tweet and Roseanne's tweet and
yes and Samantha bees statement are
different right
but you know what can you do it like if
you're running ABC you you know you're
gonna have trouble with your with your
advertisers you can't just like ignore
that that's the cap of half a billion
dollar business that she torched the
real question is like why did they not
take her phone away yes right because
that's the every other star of a TV show
every other star of a movie had to go
through something called you have to get
a physical right I have to get insurance
insurance is really important on
completion bond yeah as you can't be
insured you will not get the job that's
a good point
you know David what depressed me was not
that that you know Roseanne got in
trouble I like the idea of the show
itself it was kind of sloppy but I liked
the fact that they actually presented
some kind of civil discourse that was
missing so I was like really hopeful and
the person who presents the civil
discourse then goes ahead and shoots it
in the head I mean she actually creates
this thing and we go oh maybe the world
will change and then she tweets this
thing and then it all goes away yeah
it's kind of depressing
that's what it is it was nice I admit it
was nice to see a character on TV who
was an open communist
we had fun for a few months but now we
go back to it it's tough now it's gonna
they're gonna put the fries on on those
types of things I feel like yeah you
know it's gonna be pilot season pilot
season my agent told me yeah like make
sure they make sure the pilots out
before you put your head in the oven and
the advice I got yeah that was it that
conversation happened do you by Kathy
and be an excuse because I the reason
why I bring that up everybody knows
somebody who's had an experience with
ambien but that was that was Roseanne's
excuse do you buy that I do not buy that
okay I don't think that ambien makes you
racist I think that what she said was
unacceptable and I just don't understand
why she would think it was worth it I
mean the best thing about Twitter is not
only do you not get paid for your tweets
yes but you can also get fired for that
yes there's no upside there's no upside
I don't know why any of us are on this
app whatsoever and I say this as someone
who does absolutely literally nothing
else yeah but I don't know I think we're
all very sad what David you're gonna say
I think Twitter is actually pretty
interesting it's good you know because
before Twitter I was struggling in
obscurity and after Twitter now tens of
thousands of people know that I'm
struggling
[Laughter]
[Applause]
you should save your jokes with this
show
alright Tyrus okay what about B the
amazing thing is nobody expected
Samantha B to be fired because it was
planned I think it was planned the
audience loved it L cheered what you did
it do you think it's it's different
oh the connotation is different right
but I think she get it was recorded yeah
edited yeah watch before and they were
really excited about it so it was a
premeditated hit and when they did what
they did
chic then because there was some
backlash not because it was the right
thing to do they look back and be like
hey that was wrong and call somebody
that especially a picture of her holding
a child which i think is what it was
because the sponsors were like no we're
not good with that
yeah and it's okay I guess because she
got a pack here's where here's where it
gets weird she got away with that
because I think she was a woman because
if I would have said that on this show
and you guys will let it run oh my god
guys would have been and they grave like
I'm so sorry
there's Tyrus there's nothing we
actually can't talk to you anymore
yeah sure though I would drop you later
but Gregg like hello sorry and he had
come out here and bashed me and showed
bad videos of me and talked about he
never liked me and he was scarier day to
come to work and I was a bully and you
know me so well so quickly you know so I
feel like it's kind of one of those
things where if a man would have said
that on the same type of show he would
not be around anymore so is definitely
double standard and the other thing
where I think is on us and I kind of was
one of things that that was funny was
the president was upset about apologies
yeah
mr. president bro you don't apologize
yeah when your staffers said that stuff
about John McCain oh yeah even they'd
come out your mouth and it was wrong we
don't apologize over here and that's
something that that's been something
that the Trump and the Trump presidency
in the new Trump Republicans will
apologize for nothing yeah and for him
to be like why don't we do you pologize
this person I was like come on man like
he's got to be messing joking around
the right don't apologize now you keep
going yeah they fire each other and ruin
each other's lives and then look to us
to do the same thing and we're like nah
we're doing this right I just were I see
this outrage cycle moving so fast you
have an error that's driven by emotion
stupidity that gets the spotlight the
crowd the instant outrage and then the
company that you work for it goes holy
crap this place is going up in smoke
because they're watching Twitter and
then they they don't want primitive
damage so you're gone I just wanted one
of the things I was really offended by
when the mainstream coverage is there
like Roseanne was the she was the voice
of the red stay in through know her
character was yeah people just like for
me I loved Conan the Barbarian he was
the man I didn't know RL from novi I
really he just happened to be cool but
I'm just saying I didn't know him yeah I
like that guy and so America likes the
character they're like the family not
the person who made the racist statement
they loved the cat that's who they're
hurt by it care they don't have that
character anymore not Roseanne and
that's a very media makes her very clear
all right we got a roll up coming up a
new entry to the fake news Hall of Fame
that is
[Applause]